these countries have pre-ordered nearly
4 billion doses of coronavirus vaccines
from western drug makers
some wealthy nations have even secured
enough doses to cover every person in
the country multiple times
but developing countries that don't have
much money to buy vaccines or the
technology to develop their own
are at risk of being left behind with
nothing so china and russia are stepping
in with vaccine diplomacy
in one deal beijing will sell
coronavirus vaccines to pakistan
in exchange for testing them in the
country official statements from beijing
suggest a willingness to blur their
humanitarian and foreign policy
objectives
while russia is pursuing global prestige
it's boasting that 50 countries are
interested in its coven 19 vaccine
president vladimir putin
the whole point for russia seems to be
to plant a flag and be able to say that
this is
a russian vaccine that is saving lives
around the world
so what are china and russia getting in
exchange for their new coronavirus
vaccines
in the west private drug companies have
been largely driving each step of the
process
from research and development to
manufacturing often with financial help
from governments
but that's not really the case in russia
or china
in russia has been a state-led effort
state labs have been at the forefront of
developing the vaccines
some of these state enterprises will
also manufacture the vaccines
a lot of chinese state-owned companies
in the chinese military
are involved the government would have a
say in how they share those vaccines
abroad
both china and russia's experimental
vaccines have been fast tracked through
regulatory hurdles way ahead of their
western competitors
in july before any western country
beijing approved emergency use of
experimental vaccines
and since then hundreds of thousands of
people in china have been inoculated
outside of clinical trials
privately owned chinese firms sinovac
said its recent vaccinations were
voluntary
while a subsidiary of sinopharm didn't
say if it informed those vaccinated of
potential risks
in august russia made headlines
after having tested sputnik v on 76
people
the ministry of health registered the
vaccine russia has said the registration
is conditional and published positive
data from early clinical trials of the
shot
the vaccine while still being in trials
it is already approved for
a limited purpose in the west you have
to go through
three phases on tens of thousands of
people in order to test that many people
western drug makers have looked abroad
for volunteers
and russia and china are doing the same
china
has appeared to bring the virus under
control
within its own borders in order to test
for efficacy of a vaccine
scientists need countries where the
virus is still circulating and
preferably in countries where
the case count is still high china has
started up trials in a lot of developing
countries
as well as some wealthier states even
bahrain's crown prince is among the
participants
but russia and china's vaccines haven't
been shown to be effective
if they're handed out widely and turn
out not to work this could accelerate
the spread of the virus
these partnerships could leave countries
that are struggling to contain the virus
in a financially vulnerable position
remember pakistan in august a chinese
state drug maker made one of the first
deals with the country to test vaccines
there
but the financial terms haven't been
worked out raising questions about how
pakistan will repay
china and it's not a trivial question
because islamabad is already financially
saddled to china through beijing's
huge infrastructure building program
called the belt and road initiative
over the next 20 years pakistan will
have to pay back china 40 billion
dollars
china says islamabad owes far less for
projects that are in the works
for china vaccine diplomacy might not
just give it financial leverage
but also a political one the chinese
government and at least one private drug
maker have offered vaccines to some of
its neighbors in the south china sea
a region where china has clashed with
other countries over its territorial
claims
beijing has talked about garnering
support from countries
on territorial claims in the south china
sea in the same statements that it also
talks about deepening
vaccine-related collaboration beijing
has also decided to take a larger
leadership role by joining the world
health organization's kovacs initiative
a major effort to distribute coven 19
vaccines to poorer countries
a project the u.s has rejected
although russia doesn't have china's
deep pockets its sputnik v vaccine could
also
help it make new friends and expand its
influence
in terms of the way moscow is
approaching its
export strategy it is looking at the
middle east where it has key
trade and energy partners is looking at
brazil a huge
growing economy and it is looking at
india and
developing countries in asia it is a
major
signpost to show that russia is back on
the global stage and not just in its
traditional
expertise areas like military exports
like
energy oil and gas but also in
technology
many people still believe that china is
to blame for this global health crisis
so if china can show that it can help
stop spread the virus with a vaccine
that might ease perceptions of
china being a kind of bad actor although
many in the west note the effectiveness
of their shots remains to be proven
beijing and moscow are pushing to get a
head start in the global vaccine race
vying for prestige deals and sway